maybe mTOR. Somebody else asked a question today that I want to address too because I don't
want to have any misconceptions. So, if I tested you and I allowed you to be able to eat
some meat, okay? Why can't I have bone broth? So, I don't know that I've...
I can't have what? Bone broth. So, bone broth, B-O-E-E-B-R-O-T-H, is really hip in the natural world
these days. So, bone broth to heal your gut. You can buy Dr. Axe's bone broth. Dr. Axe is a great guy,
so it'll get me wrong, but you do not want to be using bone broth if you have any history of cancer.
And I don't think we want to be using bone broth if you have any history alive either.
Because bone broth is going to hyper spike glutamate levels. And that's really the purpose of bone broth.
Bone broth has enormous amounts of L glutamate in it. Well, L glutamate spike mTOR. And if you have a
really bad leaky gut, we want to heal those gut cells and help them reproduce quicker.
That's what spiking mTOR will do. Well, if all I have is a leaky gut issue,
a damaged gut membrane, I want to use glutamate because I want to spike mTOR so I can
cause those gut cells to reproduce quicker and I can heal them faster. Great idea.
However, if you have cancer, that's like adding gasoline to the fire.
We do not want to use glutamate. We do not want to spike mTOR.
So does eating meat do this? Well, it does. But you don't have this spike of glutamate.
So if I tested you and I said you could eat meat, you know, there's, you know, it doesn't mean
you're just going to chow on a side of beef today. But, you know, you're typically eating,
you know, a size of a palm of a hand or half of that with a meal with other vegetables and other
other carbohydrates and fats. So you're not getting this spike of glutamate like you would with
bone broth. Especially when we look at your genes and you have GAD or DAO gene defects,
then these are always big bad guys. But they're bad guys and they're out really for everybody
even before we get your genes back. We don't want to spike mTOR. So I just want to hit that hard
again. So we understand because you'll see, you know, I know you guys are inquisitive people
and you're studying, you're searching, you're learning from really good functional medicine doctors
that are teaching courses and seminars and things out there. But there's some missing information
out there too that I don't want you to get sucked out a rabbit hole with that you just have to be
careful with, you know, these doctors that are taking information that are based on
well, that will increase healing, but they're not looking at it from a perspective of cancer.
And when you don't look at it from a perspective of cancer, you don't have experience treated
a lot of cancer patients. You can really do harm to people. So you have to be careful with that.